Jared Diamond of The Wall Street Journal
Wall Street Journal has done a great job
covering this and Jared joins us live on
the scene at the ball park in West Palm
how would you recap the last two hours
Jared in some ways surprising and
another ways not surprising at all it's
not surprising is the players of the
Astros apologized for a lot but didn't
ever say what exactly they were
apologizing for they offered no
specifics just sort of general remorse
for something they did in 2017 what was
shocking I think to everybody here was
Jim crane the owner of the Astros going
out there and being emphatic about oh he
does not believe that this helped the
Astros that had no bearing on them
winning the World Series he was asked to
sort of labyrinth at comment twice in
his press conference at both times he
just plowed straight ahead so I think it
is stunning that they're out here
apologizing yet it doesn't seem to be
much sort of recognition about the
championship itself which is what it's
all about
yeah but Jared is this owner delusional
or lying he kept referring the man
pressure points mr. Manfred supported
said this that and the other well all
that Rob Manfred it says he's not
stripping but well he hasn't said
anything about sort of the extent to
which and help look they did this
hundreds and hundreds of times over the
course of the season I promise you that
we're not helping they wouldn't have
kept doing it that's just common sense
why didn't he punish his own players you
fire your manager and you fire your GM
and this had no impact on winning the
World Series
why were they fired and you did nothing
to your players he was outside that a
lot he again kept referring back to Rob
Manfred decision not to punish players
but what what I think rang hollow about
that is that we know that a main reason
why players weren't punished was because
MLB made a deal with the MLB PA not to
punish players so that they would be
able to get players to talk and we can
debate whether or not that was the right
decision by the league but it's the
decision they made and I understand why
they made it so for Jim crane to say
well the commissioner
that he decided not to punish player
it's not quite as simple as that I think
it's a fair question and Jim crane has
kept saying well what the Commissioner
said and I agree with them do you think
that Altuve and Reddick were wearing a
wire or buzzers look I have no evidence
to believe that is true we've all seen
that it was now a Tuesday video over
2019 it's really weird but so far that's
just been the realm of conspiracy
theories and I have no reason to think
otherwise I will say though there's been
a lot of weird things in this story that
a month ago or two weeks ago I would
have said it's crazy that turned out to
be true so maybe we'll find out
different but at this moment I really
had no reason to believe that's true but
it is a good conspiracy theory though I
was wondering if this owner let's say
his players were guilty of using
steroids would he have blamed the needle
what do you blamed a doctor the training
set he wouldn't he wouldn't blame the
players he would have said well they
were led down the wrong path or
something yeah he that you might be
right and the other thing he did a lot
today was we put all the blame on Jeff
Blue now AJ handy said well I fired
those guys they were the leaders they
were responsible but what he didn't say
those guys have bosses too and their
boss was you Jim McLean the owner of the
organization he made it very clear that
he does not think that he deserves any
sort of culpability for this at all it's
the people who just worked directly
underneath him if I said you got one
question you can ask to anybody involved
in this who would it be and what would
you ask oh goodness
Jose all to me were you actually wearing
a buzzer no I don't think I'll ever
answer it truthfully but if we could
make him answer that question truthfully
give him some truth serum were you
wearing a buzzer god I would love I
would love to hear an honest answer one
way or the other for them is this story
over now I think the Astros want you to
think it's over they probably wanted
this to be over a month ago yes we have
new revelations coming out constantly so
no I don't think it's going to be over
yet it's very of nothing else it's going
to be a huge story when they go on the
road all season how our pitchers get a
respond or they going to throw them
other players have not
take into this kindly you don't often
see players are throwing under other
players under the bus or criticizing out
of the player other players they're
usually pretty sort of in solidarity
with each other this situations been
different other players and other teams
made it very clear that they are upset
about this and I think it's going to be
a wild scene when they go on the road
and frankly and I also believe if there
is anymore some nefarious activity that
hasn't been uncovered it will be
eventually because if something is true
it has a way of eventually coming out
Jared thanks for joining us Wall Street
Journal's done a great job covering this
story and thank you for joining us thank
you
that's a Jared Diamond Wall Street
Journal baseball reporter down there
with the Astros for more Dan Patrick
show tune in the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]